[Music]
both of our next presenters have had the
privilege of working with Oliver Stone
who is now pretty sure that it was them
in the Texas Book Depository okay
she movingly portrayed a vietnamese
president in heaven and earth and we
love to madly as jim morrison in the
doors please welcome John Chen and Val
Kilmer
[Applause]
[Music]
while the unsung artists in our industry
none put in more hours than the people
known as the makeup artists they set up
shop before the actors come in usually
before the Sun comes up and around the
set until the shooting is done this year
eight people have been nominated for
their work on three very unique films
for the best achievement in makeup the
nominees are for mrs. Doubtfire great
canon B Neil and Yolanda to save
transform Robin Williams from a daddy
into a nanny
Carlton employed makeup and Ellen dingy
real hair as they collaborated in
bringing Tom Hanks from good health to
his gradual device in Philadelphia for
Schindler's List Chris jennasmith
Matthew Mungle and Judy Alexander Cory
with the three artists we did the
healthy hair of actresses by designing
and applying special ball caps and wigs
and the Oscar for makeup goes to greg
cannom
Vimeo and Yolanda two things down fire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Academy I want to thank my
crew Mitch Devane Lantana taro John
Logan Rowland Blanc Laura Steve crowding
Todd Tucker Keith van der Laan Larry
agayn Jim Cooper at 20th we'd like to
thank our producers Marshall Williams
John Bradshaw him mark Radcliffe my
assistant Stephon Dupree and our wig
maker Renata we'd like to thank the
Academy for their gracious consideration
for our hairstylists in this category
this year and from now on and also we
would like to thank most of all Robin
Williams for his beautiful portrayal and
his patience as mrs. Doubtfire thank you
very much thank you